One day, a tortoise who was not happy with her life said,...
..."I wish I could fly like the birds."
Hearing the tortoise, an eagle flew down and said,...
..."What will you give me if I teach you to fly?"
"I'll give you everything I have," answered the tortoise,...
...knowing very well that she had nothing to give.
"Very well," the eagle said.
And he picked the tortoise up, and flew into the sky with her.
Then the tortoise told the eagle she had nothing to give him.
The eagle said, "Then I will take your life instead," and he let go of the tortoise.
The tortoise fell to the ground below and broke into pieces.
As she was dying the tortoise said, "I have been so foolish to complain."
"I should have been happy with being alive and crawling on the ground."